what up guys welcome to the just pearly
things youtube channel and welcome to
conversations with a
maybe feminist yeah maybe i'm on the
line now mel's got some good arguments i
got some good points okay some critical
thinking's going on now some good points
so she's not sure if she's a feminist
anymore because of this channel right
yeah yeah so
i've been confronted with some ideas and
i appreciate that a lot of people won't
have conversations with people that
disagree
check this out guys studies show that
our appearance affects our mental health
and the anti-aging industry has been
capitalizing on this for decades but the
problem is is many of their serums and
their supplements fall short that is
because many of the products that are
sold on store shelves today do not
attack the root of the problem mostly
they just hide wrinkles temporarily
using cheap ingredients but don't worry
guys i have a solution for you i use
multi-collagen multi-collagen works to
restore the youthfulness of the skin it
helps combat loose skin and wrinkles
faster than anything else that i've
tried but listen to this guys the real
reason that it works is you are
supercharging your skin's collagen
intake collagen is the protein that our
skin needs in order to stay elastic this
product helps deliver collagen directly
to skin cells big secret that is why it
is so effective now look just imagine
how good you will look by summer if you
start taking it today if you want to
look your best and feel your best grab
some multi-collagen today get up to 51
off in the next 24 hours by using my
custom-made url health with pearly.com
or just visit the link that is in the
description coolest part is that if you
don't like it there is a 60-day
money-back guarantee
and i think it's a sign of maturity if
you could like recognize if an argument
is good yeah but that doesn't mean like
i won't be a feminist it's just mean i'm
thinking about it she's thinking i think
i'll take it okay i'll take it okay okay
so i a lot of the points that i make on
the show i'm quoting from this guy okay
and
jordan peterson okay so he
is a psychologist
and he um
he's very smart very intelligent and he
actually changed my life i
stopped drinking because of him
okay yeah and he i don't know he just
makes a lot of good points and this is
one of the videos that changed my mind
on feminism okay i don't know if i
should watch this then
things might happen
jordan peterson you've said that men
need to quote grow the hell up tell me
why
well because there's nothing
uglier than an old infant
there's nothing good about it
people who don't grow up don't find this
sort of meaning in their life that
sustains them through difficult times
and they're certain to encounter
difficult times
and they're left bitter and resentful
and without purpose and adrift and
hostile and resentful and vengeful and
arrogant and deceitful and and of no use
to themselves and of no use to anyone
else and no partner for a woman and
there's nothing in it that's good so you
say i mean that sounds pretty bad you're
saying the crisis of masculinity i mean
what do you do about it
you
tell
you help people understand why
it's necessary and important for them to
grow up and adopt responsibility why
that isn't uh shake your finger and get
your act together sort of thing why it's
more like but why it's more like
a delineation of the kind of destiny
that makes life worth living i've been
telling young men and but it's not i
wasn't specifically aiming this message
at young men to begin with it just kind
of turned out that way and it's mostly
you admit it's mostly men listening i
mean it is your audience well it's about
80 on in on youtube which is a youtube
is a male domain primarily so it's hard
to tell how much of it is because
youtube is male and how how much of it
is because of what i'm saying
but um
you you what i've been telling young men
is that there's an actual reason why
they need to grow up which is that they
have something to offer you know that
that
that people have within them this
capacity to set the world straight and
that's necessary to manifest in the
world and that also doing so is where
you find the meaning that sustains you
in life so what's gone wrong then
oh god all sorts of things have gone
wrong i think that
i don't think that young men are
hear words of encouragement some some of
them never in their entire lives as far
as i can tell that's what they tell me
and the fact that the words that i've
been that i've been speaking the youtube
lectures that i've done and put online
for example have had such a dramatic
impact is an indication that
young men are starving for this sort of
message because like why in the world
would they have to derive it from a
lecture on youtube now they're not being
taught that they that it's important to
develop yourself but does it does it
bother you that your audience is
predominantly
male does that isn't isn't that a bit
divisive no i don't think so i mean it's
no more divisive than the fact that
youtube is primarily male and tumblers
female isn't it tumblr is primarily
female
but you're just saying that's the way it
is well it's i'm not saying anything
it's just an observation that that's the
way it is um there's plenty of women
that are watching my lectures and coming
to my talks and buying my books it's
just that the majority of them happen to
be men uh it's what's in it for the
women though
well what sort of partner do you want
you want an overgrown child
or do you want someone to contend with
that's going to help you and that's rely
on women have some sort of duty to sort
of help fix the crisis of masculinity
but depends on what they want
no i mean it's it's exactly exactly how
i laid it out like
women want
deeply want men who are competent and
powerful and and i don't mean power in
in
in the in that they can exert tyrannical
control over others that's not power
that's just corruption
power is competence
and why in the world would you not want
a competent partner well i i know why
actually you can't dominate a competent
power partner so if you want me you
should dominate is that what you're
saying no i'd say women who have had
their relationships impaired with
impaired
their relationships with men
impaired and who are afraid of such
relationships will settle for a weak
partner because they can dominate them
but it's a sub-optimal solution
okay what do you think so far
i mean so far so good like what he's
saying
seems to make sense but he hasn't said
anything that's like controversial yeah
everything said so far is pretty like i
don't say like vanilla like nothing's
like gonna rock the boat so far uh what
do you think of her
i have nothing against her i think she's
asking bad questions okay they're very
provocative but not too profound do you
think it's valid to like ask why your
audience is men
i mean she's a journalist and she's
making something that's gonna be used to
entertain okay someone's gonna watch
this she's just gonna make it she's
stirring up
do you um i'm just gonna ask oh jordan
peterson
smash your pass
he kind of wants to have an actor but i
don't know who
are you gonna say no i'm saying
yeah i just just to be sure just to be
just a no do you think okay do you think
there's a crisis of masculinity with men
where men are as masculine as like they
used to be
i don't know if let's say it's a crisis
i think there's always been an issue
with masculinity in men there's always
been some sort of like i don't know
uncomfortableness of like defining
masculinity and defining what it means
to be a man in like all time periods i
have that feeling okay so i don't think
it's any different now than it was like
when men had to go to war and like oh be
a man go to bed i think there's still
that pressure
i don't think men are as tough as they
used to be
i guess there's a lot of men that are
addicted to corn and
and um and video games like i think
there's like a a subset like i don't
think it's the majority of men but i
think there's a large minority that
really aren't as strong as they used to
be like they used to like competent to
me just not competent in general
because like playing video games like so
many people do that like
no but i'm talking about a subset that
that are addicted to video games and
corn okay so they're just not in touch
of reality because i feel like if you do
those things
they're all virtual so like you're
interpreting like a temptation of the
world is gonna be very different from
everyone i mean like okay there's a
subset that maybe are addicted to that
stuff and have never had a girl like
them and have no social skills and just
i i don't know i think there's a us
a large minority of men that just have a
lot of issues and are very lonely okay
i can imagine that as well okay and it's
like maybe this guy
could be a savior for those kind of
people yeah yeah yeah so small solution
do you think a lot of women are doing
i think there's a substantial minority
of women who do that and i think it's
very bad for them they're very unhappy
it's very bad for their partners
although their partners get the
advantage of not having to take any
responsibility but what gives you the
right to say that i mean maybe that's
how women want their relationships those
women i mean you're making these vast
generalizations
i'm a clinical psychologist
right you're saying you've done your
research and women are unhappy
dominating men
i didn't say they were unhappy
dominating then i said it was a bad
long-term solution okay you said it was
making them miserable yes it is and it
depends on the time frame i mean there
can be
do do you agree with that that women
don't want to control their partners
like women don't want to like in general
we want a partner that's more competent
than us and we want a leader and like i
don't know about you but usually the
relationships i see where the woman is
like all in control like she kind of
hates her husband
i don't know i feel like it's really
like personality
based
but i do feel like personally i'd want
someone that's a bit more competent than
me i think that would just be a better
dynamic and i could feel that like for a
lot of women a lot of women that i know
also think that would be a better
dynamic yeah and i have no it's like
like you said a lot of women that are
very dominant like the dominant person
in a relationship it's not because the
other person in a relationship doesn't
want to
make an effort
yeah she's dominant like i'm gonna take
care of us i'm gonna do all this and the
guys are just freeloading yeah and i
think the girls kind of resent them
after some time i guess because you're
kind of like you're babysitting like you
said yeah
but like a guy it's not the same dynamic
because if a girl is like living off a
guy he's fine
see that's the thing like how come we
don't say like oh like to a woman that's
staying at home like it's like you're
free nowaday
like it's kind of like it is a bit of a
double standard like with the
masculinity we expect from men and the
femininity for women is not even on the
same level well i think men could still
like i think women were just really
unattractive to guys that don't do [ __ ]
yeah of course
i don't think men are unattracted to
women that don't like i i don't think
like women that don't have any hobbies
do you think that men like oh this woman
just got she does nothing in her free
time i don't think guys really care if
she's not like no it's so true like we
can be so intelligent guys like but
you're cute though like i think they
like it as it's a bonus right like it's
just sweet
isn't that sweet that like guys aren't
always like
this woman has to have this in this
cause like women can get a bit cynical
about things like this like oh this what
degree does this guy have i've got a
degree does he have anything
but like the guys was like oh this
girl's cute like he's cute and nice yeah
and we're like okay but like can you do
this but it's harshly it's our biology
right we can't we can't help that we had
to be selective yeah pass on the best
jeans but
but it'd be like that hey dude
i mean there can be there's intense
pleasure in momentary domination that's
why people do it all the time
but it's no formula for a long-term
successful long-term relationship that's
reciprocal right any long-term
relationship is reciprocal
virtually by definition
so
let me put a quote to you from the book
where you say there are whole
disciplines in universities forthrightly
hostile towards men these are the areas
of study dominated by the post-modern
stroke neo-marxist claim that western
culture in particular is an oppressive
structure created by white men to
dominate and exclude women
but then i want to put minorities too
dominating okay sure but i want to put
you that here in the uk for example
let's take that as an example the gender
pay gap stands at just over nine percent
you've got women at the bbc recently
saying that the broadcaster is illegally
paying them less than men to do the same
job you've got only seven women running
the top ftse 100 companies
so it seems to a lot of women that
they're still being dominated and
excluded to quote your words back to you
it does seem that way but
multivariate analysis of the pay gap
indicate that it doesn't exist
but that's just true isn't it i mean
that's nine percent kept pay gap that's
a gap between median hourly earnings
between men and women exists yeah but
there's multiple reasons for that one of
them is gender but it's not the only
reason like if you're a social scientist
worth worth your salt you never do a
univariate analysis
like you say well women
in aggregate are paid less than men okay
well then we break it down by age we
break it down by occupation we break it
down by interest we break it down by
personality but you're saying basically
it doesn't matter if women aren't
getting to the top because that's what's
skewing that gender pay gap isn't it
you're saying well that's just a fact
no i'm not saying it doesn't matter
either you're saying there are multiple
reasons for it yeah but those reasons
why why should women put up with those
reasons
why should women be content i'm not
saying that they should have put up with
it i'm saying that the claim
that the wage gap between men and women
is only due to sex is wrong and it is
wrong there's no doubt about that the
multivariate analysis have been done
multivariate analysis
i'm saying that nine percent pay gap
exists that's a gap between men and
women i'm not saying why it exists but
it exists now if you're a woman that
seems pretty unfair
you have to say why it exists but do you
agree that it's unfair if you're a woman
not necessarily and on average you're
getting paid nine percent less than a
man that's not fair is it
it depends on why it's happening
i can give you an example
okay
there's a personality trait known as
agreeableness agreeable people are
compassionate and polite
and agreeable people get paid less than
just less agreeable people for the same
job
women are more agreeable than men
again a vast generalization
that's true but that's right and some
women get paid more than men
so you were saying that by and large
women are too agreeable to get the pay
rises now i'm saying that that's one
component of a multivariate equation
that predicts
um salary
it accounts for maybe five percent of
the variance something like that so
surely you need about another twenty
about another eighteen factors one of
which is gender and there is prejudice
there's no doubt about that but it
accounts for a much smaller proportion
of the variance in the pay gap than the
radical feminists claim okay so rather
than denying the pay gap exists which is
what you did at the beginning of this
conversation shouldn't you say to women
rather than being agreeable and not
asking for a pay rise go and ask for a
pay right make yourself disagreeable
with your boss oh definitely there's
that but i also didn't deny it existed i
denied it existed because of gender okay
because i'm very very
very
careful with my words
so the pay gap exists you accept that
but you're saying
i mean the pay gap between men and women
exists but you're saying it's not
because of gender it's because women are
too agreeable to ask for pay rises one
of the reasons okay one of the reasons
so why not get them to ask for a pay
right
so one of the things that you do as a
clinical psychologist is um
assertiveness training so you might
say often you treat people for anxiety
you treat them for depression
um
and you and maybe the next most common
category after that would be
assertiveness training and so i've had
many many women extraordinarily
competent women in my clinical and
consulting practice and we put together
strategies for their career development
that involve continual pushing competing
for higher wages and often tripled their
wages within a five-year period
what do you think
he's spitting some facts i'm like i need
to learn about assertiveness because i'm
quite an agreeable person me too and i
feel like that would stop me from
getting a pay raise yeah more than my
gender
i feel like that would have been
this guy
don't do this you know paul because
paul's going to stop
changing my body yeah look at okay but
this is what bothers me and i've talked
about this in a different video okay but
not with you different one with someone
else but
feminists i think are dishonest because
i think there's no way that the people
pushing the 75 cents to the dollar
that's what they called it in the u.s
i'm sure they had some equivalent here
okay they would say oh like what why
don't they pay us the same da
i think there's no way that the people
leading those movements did not know
this
i are the people in charge okay there's
no way that nobody brought them like
this that's a great building if you're
if you're leading this whole thing so
why do you want pete women
to be mad at men is my thought because
like that's they're pushing it as if
men are the issue like against each
other yes but all the scientists are
saying that it's not
so it makes me not trust feminism as a
whole because it doesn't seem like
they're looking out for our best
interests okay because they're not
looking at both sides being equal which
is what the argument should actually be
about yeah well they're not
they want us to disdain men i think
because why else are you pushing that
okay i think that's an interesting
argument
i i get what you mean with like the
gender pay gap yeah and um women being
paid equally as one argument
and this makes sense
and this makes me like question my
values as a feminist but that's just not
the only reason that they're so feminine
right also like
general rights to work there's also like
different countries like how we're gonna
treat it like there's laws about you
know autonomy and all those stuff so i
think this is like one subset of
feminism that i'm like okay this makes
sense
but like
there's also feminists that don't
believe in rights with women of color
and stuff like that so like
feminism as a whole like i don't know if
i like you anymore but like subsets i'm
like okay well i think the only part
that makes sense to me is i'm not
pro-choice but if i was okay i could see
some
like like that would be something you
could fight before right like maybe i
have no idea what the abortion laws are
in europe but okay they're pretty lacks
compared to america really i heard
they're more strict in europe i mean in
the uk
an abortion is free okay you can go to a
healthcare provider
after i think it's the 23rd or 24th week
there's a cut-off but like for reasons
like oh my gosh after six months
23rd 24th weeks that's six months i
didn't do the math yeah yeah that is
also like for reasons like i've got too
many children i can't financially have
this kid yeah
that can be a reason or i know this
child has a disability i don't want to
have this kid because like the reasons
you do not want to have this kid
are debatable like
how serious they are or not
we we didn't expect it so like no yeah
like that's not like okay
it has to be like a solid like i don't
know a serious issue so i'd say like
they're quite lenient in comparison to
what i'm hearing about in the market
yeah okay maybe maybe i was misinformed
there but um
no so that that argument i could at
least understand because i'm like okay
like that that's why they would want it
okay but
the
like the pay gap it just makes me wonder
why are they fighting so hard for this
if it's not if
there's no way they don't know
yeah i feel like this is like a lot of
feminists that i see that have this
mindset that like
all our problems are written in men like
okay men are doing this what are men
doing for this issue
but like
as a feminist like as i don't know as a
feminist in the future but like as an
ex-feminist or in the middle
like what were we doing to help men also
have like equality what were we doing
for like not just women from like the
western world to have equality like
let's say people in a third world
country like as a feminist what did you
do exactly to make sure someone in a
different country a woman was having her
equal like having equality like i don't
feel like with as
politically correct as we like to make
ourselves seem like we're not like our
arguments aren't that
just like i don't know just as we make
it seem yeah like i just talked to so
many feminists that have this like
disdain for men i don't think it's
intentional but i think it's like kind
of rooted in ourselves it's kind of like
the culture of feminism is like really
like okay we hate our men yeah i think
like okay for most things you need a
scapegoat if something goes wrong
because yeah you kind of want to have a
big group of people to blame it on and
that's kind of where in this one
i don't know
but like i'm sorry i'm sure
conservatives have a scapegoat okay like
what's up
feminists exactly like the feminists are
the problems
yeah yeah exactly it's like there's
always something that like yeah a group
needs someone to blame and i think
that's where feminism went be like okay
you know who the best person to blame is
man
yeah i think it should be ourselves
i think we should be ourselves really i
think like
i genuinely like i swear i say this on
this i think everything's my own fault
i'll give you a deal i've been cheated
on my fault i picked the guy my own
fault
literally everything in life i feel like
is my own fault okay i forgot if a guy
does be dirty it's my fault i picked him
and then
i can learn to pick better if i'm not
getting paid if i don't feel like i'm
getting paid enough it's my fault i
don't know how to negotiate
like i just like have this world view
where everything is my fault and i'm not
going to blame anyone else that's really
good like there's like a workflow in
psychology it's called like locus of
control and yeah like internal and
external yeah so like you fell like oh
you you failed to test like my teacher's
so bad you're the kind of person like no
like i should have studied i might fail
this semester probably i swear to god
that's my own dear fault
yeah like i like that but like i feel
like with feminism like it's difficult
one because like women did go through
times where like we were oppressed right
well but okay so this is i think what
feminism gets wrong
so i don't think women were so much
oppressed
i think they were working with each
other and back then it was very
traditional and women didn't have
like they they couldn't like the reason
they couldn't vote was because they most
women didn't want to be able to vote
okay and because you would have to be
drafted
okay and so it's never been equal
because the sexes aren't equal like if
there was a draft today mostly men would
be in it
you know what i'm saying and like back
then
it we were working with each other it
made more sense for the man to work and
the woman to stay home
okay like it wasn't necessarily that
like they were hating on women and they
didn't want them to have rights or
anything it was just like that made
sense in society
okay at the time and then you know we
got birth control that gave us more
options we were able to raise up like
economically you know it made more sense
for two people to work so like but
that's more of society i just think we
have this like vision that women were
just depressed and hated their lives and
i just don't think that was the case
i i don't know about that but like i
feel like i think we do sometimes
exaggerate the past
obviously i wasn't there like i don't
know what it was like to be like a woman
in the 50s yeah who knows how good or
bad that was but like
i still feel like now like i still feel
like there was periods of time where
women okay i wanted to do something and
she couldn't maybe she was like the
exception but she still wanted to do
something she couldn't and that's why i
agree i agree that did happen yeah and i
think that's why like it matters and
that's what people feel so passionately
about it but like now like the
inceptions like there's not that many
exceptions where a woman can't do
something that she wants to yeah that's
why i question like yeah
the lens we need to go to really oppress
men back or be mean back to man for the
exception well andy and they protected
us like we couldn't defend ourselves for
a lot of history
like you needed a man to protect you
like but like society was made it was in
a way that we could only have a man to
protect ourselves like we didn't push
the
i don't think i could protect myself
that i'm six foot i think you could
handstand a strong goal i am strong but
against the 90 80 of dudes i would say
no they would win
maybe and like the world was like a
scary place at one point so i'm really
biased because i i'm when i'm a coach at
a dojo so
i just like martial arts so oh you you
might be able to kick my ass yeah
i can't sleep
but like
i get what you mean like
i think naturally like let me go into a
bit of martial arts but like this is
like a form of what it's called which is
made by a woman which focuses on angles
and using your opponent's strength
against you so i do feel like women
could protect themselves
but like
that's also like eventually not easy to
learn yeah so it's like it's kind of
ableist like i don't think every woman
or like every person yeah will be good
at martial arts i should say that period
yeah so like expecting someone to be
against someone that's naturally
bigger and stronger than i get what you
mean like by defense but i do feel like
we can do better like if women can't
take responsibility to learn to defend
themselves they don't want to feel more
safe or just buy a gun
of course so
do you actually do you agree that you
would be happy
if that pay gap was eliminated
completely because that's all the
radical feminists are saying it would
depend on how it was eradicated and how
the how how the disappearance of it was
measured and you're saying the cost of
men that's a problem oh there's all
sorts of things that it could be at the
cost of it could even be at the cost of
women's own interests
so because they might not be happy if
they get equal pay
no because it might interfere with other
things that are causing the pay gap that
women are choosing today like having
children well or choosing careers that
actually happen to be paid less which
women do a lot of but why shouldn't
women have the right to choose not to
have children or the right to choose
those demanding careers they do they can
yeah that's fine but you're saying that
makes them unhappy by and large i'm
saying that that no i'm not saying that
i'm i and i actually haven't said that
so far you're saying it makes them
miserable no i said that what was making
them miserable was having part was
having weak partners
that makes them miserable right um i
would say that many women around the age
of i would say between 28 and 32 have a
career family crisis that they have to
deal with and i think that's partly
because of the foreshortened time frame
that women have to contend with like
women have to
get the major pieces of their life put
together faster than men which is also
partly why men aren't under so much
pressure to grow up so because for the
typical woman
she has to have her career and family in
order
pretty much by the time she's 35 because
otherwise the options start to run out
and so that in that ass
yeah that is so true like i didn't think
about that as an argument for white men
like
like your own age aren't that mature but
like damn like we do have to get our
lives together like if you don't plan
that stuff and you want to have a kid
like you can't financially like like
figure that out like if you haven't got
like a house or you're not financially
stable you've got to figure all that
stuff out like
five ten years before a guy even has to
think about even having kids yeah you
guys can have a kid when he's fifty i
recognize whenever the hell he wants
evie i heard there's people in their
seventies though yeah like that stuff's
still coming like you know yeah like
girl you're done by 35 like you're in
geriatric pregnancy
and that's another thing i think
feminism lies to women about they say
get your bag get your money chase the
career yeah but they don't forget that
like
a lot of people do want to have children
like don't like just because you're
feminist doesn't mean you have to forget
all femininity that's what i really hate
about a lot of feminism like mindsets
like oh look let's be like men and
completely disregard
our natural feminine elements like like
what we naturally want to do a lot of
people naturally want to have children
and help build a family and build a home
like okay this is god that let's get
equal pay
like i feel like that's such a like
a fiscal thing to achieve okay we now we
have equal pay but like we disregarded
all the actual natural needs that we
wanted so that's just like well i think
there's going to be a lot of single
lonely women at like 45 that that didn't
prioritize a family because society told
them that this is the right way and i i
don't believe that the people in charge
of feminism like have the women's best
intentions because yeah because if you
would i would be i think i could have
all the success in my career but if i
don't have a family i think my life
would be like i would be so sad i should
be alone at christmas that would be
horrible i yeah i can't imagine being 65
and by myself i would be
that is my worst fear i could have all
the success in the world it would mean
nothing if i didn't have a family
i get what you mean that 100 but like i
feel like
you weren't right with the way that
feminism is marketed like i know a lot
of women it's like i'll be a strong
powerful man but like in doing that
forget all the other ideas that you had
about family life you have to like men
they can have both they can be
successful and also be like a dad and
all that stuff right women we have to
sacrifice like womanhood and children
and that kind of lifestyle just to
achieve like i'm like
i don't give a i don't give i don't care
that much about equal pay
but yeah and i think it's in our but i
think women want to stay home more with
the kids than men do
i don't know i don't know if i can agree
because i don't know all women but i
feel like i do you do yeah i know a lot
of women that do most girls that i know
don't wanna like even if they have the
choice to go back to work and leave the
kid with the husband i think most women
would pick to stay with the kid i know i
probably will me too like i've seen a
lot of men with kids i don't want to be
biased but like i feel like i don't know
i think women are naturally we're more
nurturing i think yeah we're more
nurturing i know there's studies on men
being um they're more playful with the
children so kids learn how to play and
like experiment and do more exploration
stuff like growing up and then with the
parent the more like comfort comfort and
like emotional support which i think is
sweet yeah but like we've disregarded
that with like modern feminism like
forget all that stuff
well it's like they don't it almost
seems like they don't have the women's
best interest at heart and they just
want like power and control but like but
like this is what i understand okay if
they don't have the woman's best
interest in mind like what is the end
goal if women do start okay like all
women stop having kids and like start
being like okay just career curricular
then like what is the end result like
who is driving that and who wants that
as an end result like who does that
benefit me
that's a good question i don't know
sorry guys they cut off for a second
we're talking about how oh you said you
don't know
who
he's like pushing like driving he's the
driving force behind like modern
feminism now i don't know let me know in
the comments section guys yeah like i
bet they have some theories yeah because
like okay
who really wants women all to go to work
stop having children stop having that
you know that permanent element like who
really wants to push that
i don't know because the end result like
what would that even be like a world
chaos like a world without families i
went without kids yeah maybe it's
someone who hates kids maybe it's like
eugenics maybe it's population control
though it makes sense that could be the
graphic
there's a lot of conspiracy theories out
there
okay let's keep run out and so that puts
a tremendous amount of stress on women
especially at the end of their 20s i
think i take issue with the idea of the
typical woman because you know all women
are different and that's what i want to
just put another quote to you from the
book different in some ways and the same
in others okay you say women become more
vulnerable when they have children and
you talk to one of your youtube
interviews about crazy happy sisters
so
simple question is gender equality a
myth in your view is that something
that's just never going to happen
it depends on what you mean by equality
getting the same opportunities
fairly people we could get to a point
where people were treated fairly or more
fairly i mean people are treated pretty
fairly in western culture already but we
can they're really not though are they i
mean otherwise why would there only be
seven women running ftse 100 companies
in the uk why why would there still be a
pay gap which we've discussed
why are women at the bbc saying that
they're getting paid illegally less than
men to do the same job that's not fair
let's go to the first question they're
both complicated questions seven seven
women repeat that one there's seven
women running the top ftse 100 companies
in the uk well the first the first
question might be um why would you want
to do that
why would a man want to do it
there's a lot of money
there's a certain number of of men
although not that many
who are perfectly willing to sacrifice
virtually all of their life
to the pursuit of a high-end career so
they'll work these are men that are very
intelligent they're usually very very
conscientious they're very driven
they're very high energy they're very
healthy and they're willing to work 70
or 80 hours a week non-stop specialized
at one thing to get to the top so you
say women are just more sensible they
don't want that because it's not an
isolated i'm saying that's part of it
definitely and so i worry
you don't think there are barriers in
their way that prevent them getting to
the top there are some barriers yeah
like other like men for example i mean
to get to the top of any organization is
an incredibly competitive enterprise and
the men that you're competing with are
simply not going to roll over and say
please take the position so let me come
back absolutely all out warfare is
gender equality a myth
i don't know what you mean by the
question men and women aren't the same
and they won't be the same that doesn't
mean they can't be treated fairly is
gender equality desirable
if it means equality of outcome then
almost certainly it's undesirable that's
already been demonstrated in scandinavia
because in scandinavia you mean by that
equality of outcome is undesirable well
men and women won't sort themselves into
the same categories if you leave them
alone to do it off their own accord i've
already seen that in scandinavia it's 20
to one female nurses to male something
like that it might not be quite that
extreme and approximately the same male
engineers to female engineers and that's
a consequence of the free choice of men
and women in the societies that have
gone farther than any other societies to
make gender equality the purpose of the
law those are inertical differences you
can eradicate them with tremendous
social pressure and tyranny but if you
leave men and women to make their own
choices you will not get equal outcomes
right so you're saying that anyone who
believes in equality whether you call
them feminists call them whatever you
want to call them should basically give
up because it ain't going to happen only
if they're aiming at equality of outcome
so you're saying give people equality of
opportunity that's fine not only fine
it's eminently desirable for everyone
for individuals and for society but
still women aren't going to make it
that's what you're really saying depends
on your measurement techniques they're
doing just fine in medicine
in fact there are far more female
physicians than there are male
physicians
there are lots of lots of disciplines
that are absolutely dominated by women
many many disciplines and they're doing
great
so let me put something else to you from
the book you say the introduction of the
equal pay for equal work argument
immediately complicates even salary
comparison beyond practicality for one
simple reason who decides what work is
equal it's not possible so the simple
question is do you believe in equal pay
well i made the argument there it's like
it depends so you don't leave an equal
pay
no i'm not saying that at all because a
lot of people listening to you will just
say i mean are we going back to the
doctor that's correct you're actually
not listening i'm just saying carefully
and i'm hearing you basically saying
women need to just accept they're never
going to make it on equal terms equal
outcomes is what how you defined it no
idea if i was a young woman watching
that i would go well i might as well
just go and play with my cindy dolls i'd
give up trying at school because i'm not
going to get the top job i want because
there's someone sitting there saying
it's not possible
desirable that's what i said it's a it's
a bad social goal i didn't say that
women shouldn't be striving for the top
or anything like that because i don't
believe that for a second striving for
the top but you're going to put all
those hurdles in their way as has been
in their way for centuries and that's
fine you're saying that's fine no no i
think i really the patriarchal system is
just silly i do i think that's silly i
really do i mean look look at your
situation you're hardly unsuccessful
yeah and i have how do you make it hard
to get exactly
good that's okay battling is good this
is all about inevitable but you talk
about men first let me just put another
thing to you from the bottom you're
saying you have to battle for a high
quality position
well i notice in your book you talk
about real conversations between men
containing quote and underlying threat
of physicality oh there's no doubt about
that what about real conversations
between women is that something are we
sort of too amenable and reasonable
no it's just that
the domain of physical conflict is sort
of off limits for you well you just said
that i fought to get where i've got yeah
but what does that mean
i don't imagine that you've yeah to some
degree i suspect you're not very
agreeable so that's the thing successful
women i'm not very agreeable right yeah
i've noticed that actually in this
conversation at least i'm sure it served
your career well successful women though
basically have to wear the trousers in
your view they have to sort of become
men to succeed is what you're saying
well if they're going i've had to fight
to succeed
against men certainly masculine traits
are going to be helpful i mean one of
the things i do in in my counseling
practice for example when i'm consulting
with women who are trying to advance
their careers is to teach them how to
negotiate and to and to be able to say
no and to not be easily pushed around
and to be formidable and you need to if
you're going to be successful you need
to be smart conscientious and tough well
here's a radical idea why don't the
bosses adopt some the male bosses shall
we say adopt some female traits so that
women don't have to fight and get their
sharp elbows out for the pay rises it's
just accepted if they're doing the same
job they get the same pay
well i would say partly because it's not
so easy to determine what constitutes
the same job and almost because
arguably yeah there are still men
dominating our industries our society
and therefore they've dictated the terms
for so long that women have to battle to
know that's not true
it's not true so for example
well i can give you an example very
quickly so i worked with women who
worked in high-powered law firms in
canada for about 15 years and they were
as
competent
and put together as anybody you would
ever meet and we were trying to figure
out how to further their careers
and there was a huge debate in canadian
society at that point that was basically
ran along the same lines as your
argument is that if the
law firms didn't use these masculine
criteria then perhaps women would do
better but the market sets the damn game
it's like and the market is dominated by
men no it's not it's not the market is
dominated by women they make 80 of the
consumer decisions that's not the case
at all if you're talking about people
who stay at home looking after children
by and large they are still women so
they're going out doing the shopping but
that is changing they make all of this
okay so the market is driven by women
not men right okay and if you're a
lawyer they still pay more for the same
sort of goods
that's been proven that men for the you
buy a blue bicycle helmet is going to
cost less than a pink one anyway we'll
come on to that partly because men are
less agreeable
right so so they won't put up with it i
want to ask you
is it not desirable to have some of
those female traits you're talking about
i'd say that's a generalization but
you've used the words female traits is
it not desirable to have some of them at
the top of business i mean maybe there
wouldn't be they don't produce a banking
crisis they don't predict success in the
workplace the things that predict
success in the workplace are
intelligence and conscientiousness
agreeableness negatively predicts
success in the workplace
you're saying that women aren't
intelligent enough to run these top
covers no i didn't say that at all you
said that
female traits don't predict success but
i didn't say that intelligence wasn't i
didn't say that intelligence and
conscientiousness well you were saying
female traits just by implication are
not female traits no no i mean that's
very dangerous not saying that at all
um okay what did you what did you think
he makes a lot of interesting points but
she had some good arguments as well like
he was like okay like
well
these law firms they work off the market
and women are consuming like what like
eighty percent of everything but like
also women are like push to stay at home
um in society so then obviously they'll
be going out shopping and doing those
kind of things
but i do think it's like argument is
correct about group wellness
i'm so agreeable i can't disagree with
this
i'm like
okay do you think that women
us it's society that wants us to stay
home or do you think women want to stay
home because we were talking about this
earlier and we both agreed that we would
rather stay home yeah but like
this is the problem like i don't know if
it's like i'm feminine and i'm agreeable
that like
right either way like how can i tell the
difference if it's society or not like
i'm an agreeable person i'm probably
going to agree that i want to do this
anyway and almost like i think society
pushes women to work with feminism they
say go get your bag it's like but you
know i think it's unfair for women is
that we're pushed to do both we push to
be like
a career have a job be intelligent get a
degree do all that stuff but on top of
that we want you to be feminine take
care of children and i feel like
it's easier for men to pick one thing
and be good at it like be like a shitty
dad but like a woman has to make the
perfect mom and also be like the perfect
career person have all these different
qualities and skills they require a lot
of effort
i don't
honestly i don't think women
are really pushed to be feminine
nowadays like if anything i think women
are pushed to be more masculine like i
think
summer that's that's a masculine trait
that's a masculine promise like that's
masculine
getting more money like that's that's
more of a matte like yeah but like we
still expected like when it comes to
certain age like we will have this thing
we're like oh look when you're gonna
have a kid when you get married are you
engaged if how many tricks do like they
they are like still there oh where
makeup that kind of stuff well i think
the problem is men we still want men to
be attracted to us and men are attracted
to more feminine traits
and so it's like you can't really have
both you become masculine if you like or
yeah like in the workplace and that's
kind of the opposite of when you if you
want a partner but men can be like they
do masculine thing it's it's
like yeah and they get more successful
and more power that's attractive to us
but like men don't like they don't care
so like
you're saying like feminism is like send
women around in circles so like we won't
get an attract we won't find a partner
we'll be in a job that would probably be
miserable like getting sent in the wrong
direction for like the woman's best
interest is like basically yeah
yeah like i think women naturally want
to have a family i think feminism
doesn't push that i think they push you
to be promiscuous which is going to make
it harder to find a husband
they they tell you to prioritize your
career over a you don't need a man which
is going to make it hard men aren't
attracted to that it's going to make it
harder to find a husband and then on top
of that like i just think
like they they push
statistics that aren't true
i guess i guess there's a lot of things
i'm learning here but this is like very
very much towards gender pay yeah and i
feel like gender pay is not like
the best way to measure fairness for men
and women in society okay it's like such
a small part of like well i judge as
fairness like i think like maybe like
what my concern as a feminist is like
maybe my safety okay like if i'm walking
out alone how safe am i that's not fair
between me and man gender pain like
nine percent that's
it is significant but it's not something
that i'm like okay i don't i'm not
motivated by money that much yeah i'm
motivated by success in other measures
so it's like that doesn't affect me that
much i'm not very passionate about that
and i don't think it's like a fair way i
don't think it's a good judge of thrones
yeah
well the only thing is um i'm saying
like okay um
feminism
you don't think it's a measure of
fairness okay so you your concern is the
safety aspect yeah men are more likely
to be victims of a violent crime that's
one but like men are more violent true
that's true but the second thing is you
know what would make it equal well a gun
never stops
are women less intelligent than men no
longer no they're not no the the data on
that's pretty clear the average iq for a
woman in the average iq for a man is
identical there is some debate about the
flatness of the distribution which is
something that james damore pointed out
for example in his memo but there's no
difference at all in general cognitive
ability there's no difference to speak
of in conscientiousness women are a bit
more orderly than men and men are a
little bit more industrious than women
but the difference isn't big but only
that averages into any men who aren't
necessarily well of course
why are they not feminine traits why are
they not desirable at the top of
feminine traits why are they not
desirable
it's hard to say i'm just laying out the
empirical evidence like we know that we
know the traits that predict success but
we also know because companies by and
large have not been dominated by women
over the centuries we have nothing to
compare it to
it's an experiment true and it could be
the case that if companies modified
their behavior and became more feminine
than they would be successful but
there's no evidence for it i'm not
neither doubtful nor non-doubtful
there's no evidence why not give it a go
as the radical because the evidence
suggests well it's fine if like if
someone wants to start a company and
make it more feminine and compassionate
let's say and caring in its overall
orientation towards its workers and
towards the marketplace then that's a
perfectly reasonable experiment to run
my point is that there is no evidence
that those traits predict success in the
workplace and there's positivity being
tried well that's not that's not really
the case women have been in the
workplace for what at least
ever since i've been around the
representation of women in the workplace
has been about 50 so we've run the
experiment for a fair fairly reasonable
period of time but not you know
certainly not for centuries let me move
on to another debate that's been very
controversial for you um
and this is you got in trouble for
refusing to call trans men and women by
their preferred personal pronouns
no that's not actually true i got in
trouble because i said i would not
follow the compelled speech dictates of
the federal and provincial government i
actually never got in trouble let me
explain this really quick so he was
against
he
there was a law in canada saying
that he needed to call trans people by
their preferred pronouns
okay and he said that that is that law
shouldn't exist because you can't tell
me what to say
and that's okay that's what they're
arguing about he said if the trans
person was in in his class he probably
would
but like his point was the government
can't dictate speech like freedom of
speech yes okay so just just to point
out like i do think like if someone has
pronouns like just use them like if
someone tells you like oh like this is
my actual name but everyone calls me
like anna like just do it yeah i'll be a
[ __ ] yeah
yeah um i i'm with like if i met someone
i was trans i i'd probably use whatever
pronouns yeah but
like i agree with like i don't believe
the government can dictate speech
okay because yeah right now so he's
going to talk more about no that's not
actually true i got in trouble because i
said i would not follow the compelled
speech dictates of the federal and
provincial government i actually never
got in trouble for not calling anyone
anything right that didn't happen
wouldn't follow the change of law which
was designed once it was discriminated
all they said it was designed to do okay
you cited freedom of speech in that why
should your right to freedom of speech
trump a trans person's
right not to be offended
because in order to be able to think you
have to risk being offensive i mean look
at the conversation we're having right
now
you know like you're certainly willing
to risk offending me in the pursuit of
truth why should you have the right to
do that it's been rather
uncomfortable i'm i'm very glad i put
you on this part
you get my point it's like you're you're
doing what you should do which is
digging a bit to see what the hell is
going on and that is what you should do
but you're exercising your freedom of
speech to certainly risk offending me
and that's fine i think more power to
you as far as i'm concerned
except you haven't sat there and
i'm sorry
ha gotcha you have got me you have got
me i'm trying to work that around my
head yeah it took a while
you have voluntary you have voluntarily
come into the studio and agreed to be
questioned
a trans person in your class has come to
your class and said they want to be
called that's never happened
and i would call them she so you would
so you've kind of changed your channel
no no no i said that right from the
beginning what i said at the beginning
was that i was not going to seed the
linguistic territory to radical leftists
regardless of whether or not it was put
in law
that's what i said and then the people
who came after me said well you must be
transphobic and you'd mistreat a student
in your class it's like i never
mistreated a student in my class i'm not
transphobic and that isn't what i said
well except you've also called trans
campaigners authoritarian haven't you i
mean isn't that
only in the broader context of my claims
that radical leftist ideologues are uh
authoritarian which they are saying
someone who is trying to work out their
gender identity who may well have
struggled with that had quite a lot of
time struggles
you're comparing them with you know
chairman mao who you know just saw the
deaths of millions of people even if the
activists you know they're trans people
too they have a right to say these
things yeah but they don't have a right
to their whole community compare them to
chairman mao
you know i could pinochet or gusto
punisher i mean that you know this is
grossly insensitive i didn't compare
them to pinochet well i did compare the
authority he was an authoritarian he was
a right winger though i was comparing
them to the left-wing totalitarians and
i do believe they are left-wing
on the mao millions of people died right
i mean there's no comparison between a
mao
why not
because trans activists aren't killing
millions of people
the philosophy that's guiding their
utterances is the same philosophy
you understand what he's talking about a
little bit so it's like it's just the
government overreach
yeah he's like talking about freedom of
speech and she's comparing to some
person that would say oh people having
to believe this yeah the authoritarians
are like okay you have to do this
because i believe this and he's like
okay they're taking that mindset
with this yes with this proposition
about pronouns right because looking at
pronouns it's not like
people are dying it's like that approach
to an argument it's it's the you don't
know if the government like because if
they do pronouns then why not something
else why not like it's it's a slippery
slope if you allow one law similar
similar to like the trans community
initially we let caitlyn jenner get that
courage award right
now now we have biological men competing
against women
like because the allowances and stuff
yeah because they allowed it in the
beginning yeah and that that's like his
point okay
but overall
what did you think
i think like he makes some valid points
like obviously he i don't know if he is
really transphobic or not so i don't
know this guy at all yeah and i wouldn't
be happy to support someone that is
transphobic just getting that out there
yeah but his argument isn't to do with
like transphobia to do with like someone
controlling what you can't say and what
you can't say simply but yes that i
completely agree with and the way that
he put it i agree with and what did you
think of that where he said gotcha i was
uh no because the thing is like he must
have been waiting for this moment
because he's been like getting grilled
this whole time since we've got a
question after question question first
pause the first time you like he kind of
compliments her like you know what like
i respect you being like prepared for
then she's like
you know
what but like yeah
i wouldn't be i'd let you be good at
this
i'm like you'd be good at like out
asking the questions
yeah i mean i learned a lot of my [ __ ] i
give jordan peterson so much credit
you've heard me cite some of this yeah
yeah yeah but like he's like so smart
he's very well spoken and like he's so
careful with how he speaks like he's not
just saying something like you know he
knows what he's saying yeah
and he really understands what he's
saying which just makes a huge
difference because i think her arguments
aren't always
a direct response to what he's actually
saying no it's like a different question
all together yeah like i have noticed
that
the pearl christmas
lights
have changed feminism is trash
okay pay gap that's questionable
feminists get back to me on that okay
what's your what's your take on this
yeah answers feminism where yeah what's
this what's the standpoint what's this
yeah come on let us if there's something
you want us to react to next time that
like maybe maybe we'll prove prove that
i missed point i'm pretty agreeable i
could change my mind she could go either
she could yeah like who knows
no no i'm really scared
okay guys um don't forget to subscribe
subscribe to the channel do you have any
social media you want to plug um at
tiana park stanley on instagram that's
basically yeah i'll put her link in the
description
she's single slide into the dms
um guys don't forget to subscribe to the
channel ring that notification bell
swear to god you watch two of these
videos and you don't subscribe we have
beef okay
i will talk to you guys next time bye